that's a very a very uh troublesome
account during the idea guys saga where
the idea guys convinced chris that they
were holding chrysler rose to their
their love interest at the time hostage
and they were torturing her so in order
to stop them from torturing her chris
was forced to do
many other things such as um
film videos
like urinating on the floor and then
having like on a carpet or like a
laminated wood floor
i think it was the carpet
oh again the worst choice [ __ ] man like
oh okay i think it was the carpet
because i didn't get to that part in the
dock so
i'll get to it later but anyway yeah so
then then chris was
was told to have pretend sex with a
pillow while all star by smash mouth
played in the background
i'm sorry that's that's just funny no
it's terrible it's almost funny to think
about but then at the same time
[Laughter]
other and another trolling group at a
later point leaked these these videos on
chris's on twitter right um yeah but
anyway also the idea guys managed to
extort over six thousand dollars out of
chris
um
okay that's not cool that's not cool
yeah and um this is where the owner of
the qb farms and and another elite group
of former trolls got together
content
we're an hour and a half in and we never
even mentioned the man in the pickle
suits i can't believe this
how could we forget the man in the
pickle suits
oh of course
this was an earlier trolling attempt
back in 2009
2008 2009 where chris went on a
real-life
date if you will with a female troll
posing as a girlfriend
who was then
yeah who was who was then uh snatched
away by a man in the pickle suit because
chris
hated pickles because it reminded them
of penises of course
they're super straightforward
not that he doesn't like eating pickles
oh they hate pickles too all pickles
eaten or just seen anyway
anyway the guy behind the pickle suits
costume uh is actually the administrator
of the quickie
and he's one of the moderators on the
christian forum on kiwi farms so he's
like a big shot still wait wait so so a
dude in an actual pickle suit arrived
yes during the day yes and took the girl
yes
[Music]
you know what if if that happened to me
as well this is so early on that i think
i've forgotten about this part 11 by the
way clearly a rick and morty fan yeah
okay so
what is this
turned up
oh my god funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen
i've ever seen
so this what does it have to do with the
elite trolls uh so
the man in the pickle suit and the owner
of the kiwi farms and another another
troll got together and seized chris's
discord account which was used to
communicate with the idea guys and from
there they found all this information
and um they found then the addresses and
names of the idea guys and tried to
report them to the fbi actually
because this was a
extortion of money across across state
lines so it was a it was a federal
offense right yeah so they even called
the idea guys mothers
uh
to no avail uh i mean because i assumed
they were old children right
teens at least or maybe early twenties
just get the [ __ ] out of them though
probably i think they uh stopped after
after that oh yeah but yeah there was
there was no case against them uh chris
is still out six thousand dollars geez
well they were out until
until a gofundme was established by the
owner of the kiwi farms to get chris a
plane ticket and uh to to go to a my
little pony convention in california oh
yeah they raised over five thousand
dollars and like maybe less than the
week after that was the phone call
concerning chris's mother right they're
about to just go to my little pony
because they were obsessed with my
little pony and uh
because of course and the sonic series
and i remember there was a whole series
of chris complaining about sonic and the
new series
right
that was back in 2014. goddamn there was
also like the my favorite like troll who
was like the
probably the most talented role like the
liquid crisp one is that what it's
called that's very good we should just
go in chronological organizations i
skipped everything i'm just i'm sorry
because it's not really that important
to the story but also this
the liquid chris is probably my favorite
part because it's probably the most
tasteful in all of this i love as well
how every time a point is brought up you
you say that the date like it's like a
real historical thing oh yes of course
1945 germany
december 2014 when it all happened and i
know how people feel when one piece fans
talk about their arcs now it's like oh
yeah the the big mom
i'd say the only the only like tasteful
troll in my opinion was liquid yeah uh
where someone did a
spot-on impression of chris's uh speak
uh
and
filmed videos as chris
and taunted chris uh by like
saying they were the real chris
and it was very it was very very well
done right and the the way that they
would speak is like it's very good right
yeah yeah and they would they challenged
chris to like a sing-off or something
yes um how this started was liquid chris
as as he became referred to uh actually
started posting videos on youtube as
chris just for the entertainment of his
friends yeah and then after a while
trolls noticed this and
wrote emails to chris about it saying oh
this guy's trying to steal your identity
you should probably address this and
this is how they they became involved
with each other and um to prove to prove
who was the real chris uh they would do
several things like for for example the
real i mean the actual real quest chris
or solid chris
as they were referred to at this time
so anyway solid chris posted their like
real address their phone number they're
proving it was them yeah oh my god
so why
because they were the real they were the
real ones only they would know chris
it's like that meme of like someone who
when it's like hacker who knows my
address me who knows it longer
it's literally that meme yeah
so yeah and then after that chris solid
chris decided that that the best way to
to go about proving this was to do a a
sync star challenge where they would
pick three songs for the other to sing
or was like right
something like that but anyway
um the best singer
would um would be voted uh
the champions league [ __ ] american
idol
we saw how chris chose this that's what
and they um
amazing because liquid chris was
actually a pretty good singer
and very good
i'm very good at playing guitar playing
guitar so like i actually like just
killed the songs
and chris was terrible that's what was
so amazing about it is that it was so
funny oh my god yeah
and then uh yeah and after the contest
was over according to a technicality
liquid chris one and then
and then
they decided to to call it quits and and
leave and uh according to the liquid
chris storyline on on youtube
he went out to get married with his with
his girlfriend and then and then go to
uh richmond
and uh make uh like join nintendo and
and make a sonichu game for example
yeah and then chris was very angry with
that because they weren't the ones
making the sewing machine right yeah the
fake christmas it was very well done
trolling actually it was like where
you're like okay trolling isn't too bad
sometimes very tasteful very funny that
just seems like the tasteful prank yeah
yeah basically because because there's
no repercussions in there right so it's
just good fun i was getting hurt i just
feel like that is just good content yeah
that's good content i mean solid chris
was very angry it produced really
entertaining videos like life ruining
things yeah it's just not extortion of
money or anything like that right
exactly compared to the other stuff like
oh wow something somewhat tasteful yeah
right and then obviously there was the
whole saga uh with chris and sonic and
chris and sonic yes so
like the real sonic sonic the hedgehog
right yes
okay not the fast food chain yeah
that's the difference sonic anyway this
sonic this was in relation to the new
sonic game at the times sonic boom sonic
boom that's it yeah the the new tv show
and game
which was um which of course featured
very wild redesigns of the characters
including uh sonic the hedgehog with
blue arms which was incredibly offensive
to christine right right incredibly
offensive oh my god
um
they were very angry right crystal rant
on facebook and they would demand that
uh gamestop would stop selling sonic
boom um they would even buy sonic boom
merchandise
and break it apart and like paint and
repaint their their arms 10.
and um jesus and
they encouraged the boycott of sonic
boom even though they they were
purchasing sony boom toys themselves
so yeah and then of course
they went to a gamestop
um and they and they tried to change the
sonic boom um game game covers with with
one saying please don't buy this game
sonic's arms are not blue and chris was
banned for that
and then chris went back again
uh around christmas 2014
and then
they were kicked out again but during
this point someone noticed that chris
was there they started filming a short
video on their phone and on their way
out chris pepper sprayed a gamestop
employee
[Music]
it just doesn't sound real one thing i
want to know is has chris ever had like
a single
real
friend
in their life
have they ever have they had ever had
like an actual human connection i guess
there are gal pal from the game store
which chris chris ruined that with that
with that image right yeah probably that
so that was probably the one time where
they had somewhat of a chance yeah
because because she actually had um
the friend actually had a brother who i
think was also on the autism spectrum so
she was more understanding of of chris's
needs
right yeah
but obviously not that understanding
yeah pretty much everyone in chris's
life failed chris in every single way
which makes this a very tragic story i
mean
it's just it's sick it's [ __ ] up and
it's also sad right because it just
seems like chris has just never had like
a proper human connection
in their life and yeah that's that's you
know that's that's pretty [ __ ] because
everyone needs like a real human
connection and if the only connection
you're getting and the only
communication you're having is with
internet trolls i'm not just like light
internet trolls but like i think i would
lose my mind if i had that yeah yeah
yeah exactly i would actually go insane